[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París el programa semanal de
radiofrance internacional en
colaboración con la televisión France 24
en español en la que cada semana damos
la palabra representantes de la sociedad
civil los políticos los deportes la
cultura y gente también de las ciencias
y de las artes el próximo mes de junio
habrá elecciones en Guatemala será
elegido el presidente de la república
160 legisladores y 300 alcaldes esa cita
que normalmente Debería ser un ejercicio
de democracia se encuentran marcada por
innumerables decisiones antidemocráticas
y por la persecución de quienes intentan
haya justicia en ese país para hablar de
la situación en el país centroamericano
hoy nos acompañan Virgilio Álvarez
Aragón sociólogo director ejecutivo de
gaceta punto GT bienvenido Virgilio y
placer tenerlo con nosotros y también
Pablo René Estrada defensor de los
Derechos Humanos miembro de la
Organización de familiares de los
desaparecidos de Guatemala bienvenido
Muchas gracias gracias por tenerlos a
los dos por nosotros Virgilio en 1996 se
firmaron los acuerdos de paz en ese país
que pusieron fin a la guerra civil que
había durado de 1960 a 96 estamos
hablando de 36 años dejó un saldo de
aproximadamente 200 mil muertos más de
40.000 desaparecidos ese acuerdo de paz
fue presentado con un modelo en su
momento que ha fallado en su ejecución
básicamente Y gracias por la invitación
El problema es que los acuerdos de paz
fueron firmados para tener una paz para
que nada cambiara en el país
Lamentablemente
fue un acuerdo que en primer lugar no se
aprobaron en como ley ya en el momento
que llegamos a la consulta popular se
pierde la consulta popular y quedan como
recomendación Durante los primeros años
son primeros años de Esperanza los
primeros 10 años de este siglo son 10
años en que esperábamos que realmente
Los acuerdos de paz se convirtieran en
la agenda política y social del país
pero todo fue todo lo contrario cada vez
se empezó a retroceder se empezó a
retroceder especialmente en las
conquistas sociales digamos sí que los
acuerdos de paz pusieron en
el mapa nacional político y social a los
pueblos indígenas son actores que ya no
puedan a regresar al olvido pero son
actores también que no han recibido el
total resarcimiento de
de todas las de todos los daños que se
hicieron a aquella época Pero por otro
lado también los acuerdos de paz no
fueron capaces de cambiar la mentalidad
del ejército de Guatemala
la doctrina política la doctrina militar
siguió siendo la doctrina de la
seguridad nacional y no como esperábamos
una doctrina de la seguridad democrática
el que tengamos en este momento las
dificultades en los juicios a los
militares es porque el ejército no ha
sido capaz de pedir perdón el ejército
no ha formado a sus nuevos oficiales en
una visión democrática de acuerdo ese es
el problema Gracias Ahora bien Pablo
René justamente hay un documento que
tiene que ver con la presencia de los
militares en la política y en la vida
social de Guatemala un documento que se
llama el diario militar que narra lo que
sucedió entre 1983 1985 donde estaban
los militares en el poder habla de lo
que sucedió con 195 personas
concretamente Víctimas de esa represión
hay un elemento que surge de los
acuerdos de paz del 96 que es la
justicia transicional Qué es esto de la
justicia transicional bueno en Guatemala
la justicia transicional lo que trata de
de juzgar digamos o de reparar son todas
estas violaciones a derechos humanos que
fueron parte de la política Estatal
genocida la política Estatal de
desaparición forzada la cual pues
actualmente la hemos evolucionando a una
política Estatal de criminalización y
persecución política no en la justicia
tradicional en Guatemala ha sido
impulsada por las víctimas desde la
desde todavía estaba el conflicto armado
interno hay casos que se juzgaron en ese
momento y han habido avances que han
permitido al menos en 25 sentencias a
nivel nacional poner sobre la mesa del
sistema genocida Pero sobre todo una
política Estatal impulsada que le dio
continuidad a la estrategia
contrainsurgente enmarcar la doctrina de
seguridad nacional y en los manuales
vigentes manuales militares vigentes en
la época los cuales sabemos que existen
sabemos que que fueron aplicados y que
actualmente vemos que todavía los los
llaman de seguridad nacional pareciera
que seguimos en la guerra solo que ahora
con votaciones durante esa guerra la
mayoría de las víctimas fueron las
comunidades indígenas de origen Maya
notablemente este diario militar hace
referencia a 195 Víctimas de manera
breve Qué significa desa195 víctimas en
un contexto donde hubo más de 200.000
Muertos claro
el documento diario militar es un
documento elaborado por una estructura o
unas varias estructuras que integran el
sistema clandestino ilegal de
inteligencia que estuvo vigente en la
época las personas que se encuentran ahí
detallados fueron personas que fueron de
interés para para el ejército para
obtener información hay personas hay
líderes campesinos hay líderes
sindicales líderes estudiantiles y
miembros de las organizaciones
revolucionarias que estaban en ese
momento tratando de derrocar a la
dictadura de Oscar Humberto Mejía
vítores de acuerdo Virgilio este próximo
25 de marzo se va a cerrar la campaña
para el registro de candidatos a la
presidencia notablemente pero también al
congreso lo que hemos señalado en un
inicio ahora bien el problema es que dos
de las principales instancias que se
supone deberían preservarse el pilar de
lo que es la democracia en ese país el
tribunal supremo electoral y la Corte
Suprema pues se puede decir que han
violado precisamente los principios de
lo que sería esa democracia
Sí es que el proceso de construcción de
la nueva dictadura en Guatemala empezó
con la salida de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad vamos
a volver sobre
en la con la salida de la sisic arranca
todo el proceso de reconstrucción de
regresión a la situación de la Guatemala
de los años 80 en consecuencia lo
primero que hizo el grupo en el poder
fue controlar la Corte Suprema de
Justicia llevamos cuatro años en que
debería haber sido electa y no ha sido
electa la nueva corte constitucionalidad
eso está en una malformación ya es un
hecho realmente lamentable pero el
ejército el el congreso no elige porque
es una Corte Suprema de Justicia puesta
a dedo para poder cumplir con todo lo
demás que es todo lo demás controlar
todo el sistema de Justicia por eso los
operadores de Justicia han tenido que
salir del país porque están siendo
perseguidos por el propio sistema de
Justicia entonces este proceso electo es
un proceso electoral marcado por un
fraude electoral que ya se cometió el no
permitir participar a una de las fuerzas
políticas que quedó en el cuarto lugar
de las elecciones pasadas que es Telma
Telma Cabrera y el exprocurador de los
Derechos Humanos Jordán Esto hace que ya
el sistema tiene las cartas marcadas los
cualquiera de los que lleguen al poder
no van a cuestionar este sistema de
cooptación de la justicia y de la
economía del país a este propósito Pablo
rende precisamente desde el 2015
empezaron a ver señales de alarma de
distintos organismos internacionales
diciendo que no se estaban cumpliendo o
que se estaba vetando lo que eran los
instancias que tiene que garantizar la
democracia y el ejercicio de la justicia
en ese país hacíamos referencias Ni más
ni menos que en el 2019 por ejemplo lo
que fue la la comisión que tendría que
investigar una serie de hechos de
corrupción en el país pulsada más
recientemente las instancias que habían
sido creadas Durante los acuerdos de paz
también han sido cerrados en qué queda
la justicia transicional en este sentido
Pues nosotros como víctimas seguimos
impulsando los casos de Justicia
tradicional nunca ha habido en Guatemala
una buena voluntad de parte del Estado
de querer y de los gobiernos de turno de
querer juzgar estos delitos Por qué
Porque son los mismos violadores de
Derechos Humanos los mismos genocidas
los que ahora son los corruptos actuales
no los que ahora ponen a los presidentes
y los quitan eso ha mermado mucho
también la capacidad del sistema de
Justicia ha habido persecución de casos
emigrantes que toca a estas personas
digamos en el caso diario militar Fue
capturado el general González taracena
Marco Antonio González taracena esta
persona fue ministro de defensa y fue
uno de los fundadores del partido fs
nación que llevó a Jimmy Morales al
poder Y actualmente Alejandro yamatei
con el con el partido vamos entonces
vemos que también todas estas instancias
del sistema de Justicia han tratado de
ser desmanteladas o debilitadas por los
mismos actores del pasado del presente
no
jueces varios periodistas han tenido que
salir de Guatemala recientemente y en el
pasado reciente justamente porque
trataron de hacer que se impusiese la
los derechos en ese país que se hiciese
justicia el día de ayer el senado en
Estados Unidos ha hecho un llamado al
presidente biden dijéramos a poner mucho
más atención a la violación de Derechos
Humanos en Guatemala Cómo reciben esa
señal procedente de Washington pues lo
vemos con buenos ojos que esperemos que
sean más duros ya que creemos que
realmente no solo para aparecer en la
lista engels es suficiente hay que ver
también la ley magninsky también sabemos
de que tienen inversiones En Estados
Unidos y ya son empresarios a nivel
transnacional también entonces vemos con
buenos ojos sin embargo nos preocupa de
que digamos en esta en esta carta que se
le pida biden o sea mencionen al juez
Miguel Ángel Gálvez sin embargo no hayan
medidas contundentes para lo que le pasó
a él que fue que lo obligaron o sea
exiliarse y a renunciar vemos también
con preocupación de que están
actualmente están queriendo pasar
amnistías de punto final de manera o sea
de manera ilegal por medio de amparos
que se le está dando de medidas
sustitutivas a los a los grandes
violadores a derechos humanos no
Entonces si vemos con buenos ojos y
esperemos de que sea un O sea que aporte
a la lucha de las víctimas pero sobre
todo al Estado de derecho en Guatemala
Pablo
decíamos los tres últimos presidentes
han sido acusados precisamente por
hechos de corrupción o torpes molinas se
encuentra en prisión ha sido condenados
y no mal recuerdo dieciséis años acusado
de corrupción su sucesor Jime Morales
que fue el que expulsó a la comisión que
tenía que ver internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala también está
acusado de corrupción el actual
presidente Alejandro yamatei Igualmente
acusado de haber utilizado fondos para
su campaña electoral hay una dijéramos
una continuidad de estos hechos sin que
se pueda garantizar una verdadera
democracia Pero qué pasa con la sociedad
la llamada sociedad civil
la sociedad civil en Guatemala está
trabajando y está luchando pero
lamentablemente está desarticulada yo
escribí un libro sobre lo que lo que
sucedió exactamente en las
movilizaciones de 2015 y lo llamo una
Revolución que nunca fue por qué porque
al final de cuentas que controla la
corrupción quien controla al congreso
quien controla todo lo que está
haciéndose en la política en Guatemala
es el empresariado el alto empresariado
la oligarquía guatemalteca tiene el
control de todas las llaves ellos son
parte de la represión ellos son parte de
la corrupción En consecuencia
manipulan la presencia de la de la de la
sociedad civil la critican si los
trabajadores toman una calle ellos salen
a decir que eso es ilegal y que no puede
ser y el estado actúa en contra de los
manifestantes pero cuando los
empresarios hacen cualquier boicot Eso
es libertado democracia de acuerdo eh
Pablo Hernández de manera muy breve
porque el tiempo se nos va Yo sé que
usted está iniciando una gira por Europa
Cuál es el objetivo entiendo que tiene
que ver en torno a la cuestión
precisamente los desaparecidos durante
el régimen militar en Guatemala háblenos
muy brevemente de eso por favor sí
efectivamente estoy haciendo una gira
por Europa en la cual estamos
evidenciando los retrocesos que hemos
tenido los golpes los retos sobre los
procesos de Justicia transicional
También estamos denunciando las las
decisiones arbitrarias y legales que
están que se están emitiendo de las
Cortes que están cooptadas en cuanto las
amnistías de punto pareciera que
quisieran implementar una política de
olvido y de impunidad y sobre todo se
nota que los últimos tres gobiernos hay
un hay un hay un desprecio por las
víctimas o sea realmente no hay no hay
una voluntad política querer escuchar y
querer solventar los crímenes que se
cometieron por parte del Estado y el
terrorismo que ejerció el estado hacia
las víctimas guatemaltecas y
guatemaltecos que seguimos luchando por
encontrar a los 4 5.000 detenidos
desaparecidos Pues el tiempo se nos va
yo agradezco a Virgilio Álvarez Aragón
su presencia en este escala en París lo
mismo que a Pablo René Estrada a ustedes
les damos cita la próxima semana aquí en
otra escala en París
[Música]